move the orange dot to negative 2 plus
2i so we have a complex number here it
has a real part negative 2 has an
imaginary part you have 2 times i and
what you see here is we're going to plot
it on this kind of two-dimensional grid
but it's not our traditional coordinate
axes in our traditional coordinate axis
you're plotting a real x value versus a
real y coordinate here on the horizontal
axis that's going to be the real part of
our complex number and our vertical x is
going to be the imaginary part so in
this example this complex number our
real part is the negative two
and then our imaginary part is a
positive two
and so that right over there in the
complex plane is the point negative two
plus two i
let's do a few more of these so 5 plus
2i once again real part is 5 imaginary
part is 2
and we're done
let's do two more of these
1 plus 5i
1 that's the real part plus 5i right
over that im
all right let's do one more of these
4 minus 4i real part is 4 imaginary part
is negative 4
is negative 4.
and we're done